ce
[Musique]
soir les enfants bonsoir un ponceau
publie ce soir je vais raconter une
histoire à nicolas pas pro d'elle une
histoire qu'ils aiment beaucoup début
dit début dit le chat le
débit des buts et des buts
bon soit en
jk la dune raconte une histoire oui une
histoire de la petite philippine et de
son lap à blanc d'accord
[Musique]
je me pose
là
écoutez bien
nous ne pouvons pas emmener ce lapin
avec nous en vacances
dit le papa de philippines à sa petite
fille ronde et coquine il faut le
laisser à la campagne j'ai dit mais le
lapin blanc avait disparu
philippines et sa maman hurbal cherché
partout dans la maison sous les lits
derrière les portes
il tint un trouvera
seul à penser sauver tant pis pour lui
allons partons
sinon nous allons manquer l'avion piquer
ce qu'il a dit filippi de tête un peu
triste que le lapin blanc se soient
sauvés mais elle était aussi fort
contente car elle n'avait jamais fait de
voyages en avion elle ouvrait de grands
yeux et regardé par le hublot la terre
et les maisons qui étaient tout petits
quand une jolie demoiselle
forte élégant
c'est une hôtesse de l'air pause a
devant elle un plateau sur lequel était
servi un copieux petit déjeuner vous
l'unité n'est qu'un feu d'huile
avec de la confiture de prunes
d'orange ou de phrases
mais à ce moment là
la valise de la petite fille se mit à
faire des bonds terrible et boum
badaboum
elle tomba sur la tête d'un gros
monsieur
et s'ouvrit
et le lapin blanc se précipita dans les
bras de filippi
début du début du
[Musique]
et les deux amis pris ensemble un
excellent petit déjeuner
avec beaucoup de confiture l'offreur
[Musique]
et voilà les enfants l'histoire est
terminée vous l'avez aimé oui eh bien je
vous donne le livre merci mme schick
alors ça nous en fait cette toute une
collection à présent nous allons au lit
[Musique]
bonne nuit chronos et nuit
boloni des enfants
fait pour heures
[Musique]
oh
piti piti piti ma parole mais c'est le
lapin blanc mais non patron c'est moi
nounours
je vous ai bien attraper allons en route
gros farceur bonne nuit les enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents faites
bien votre toilette n'oubliez pas que
vous l'avez lu tout est fait pour
[Musique]
on
bon
oh